I feel like this could be the shortest
review ever just by saying this movies
meet the parents meets Angry Birds done
[Music]
Rio - so in Rio - the Blue Bird voiced
by Lex Luthor is married and he has kids
and they're like we're the last blue
birds of our kind on the planet so we
got to be really careful however they
get wind that there might be other
really cool blue birds like them in
Brazil something like all right let's go
so they go down to Brazil and there are
more birds down there they're trying to
mingle but Lex Luthor this Jesse
Eisenberg don't want to confuse anybody
but you know the main bird he's voice
but Jesse Eisenberg he's a city bird so
he's trying to fit in you know it's that
whole thing then deforestation is
happening so now they have to deal with
that and a bunch of other things that
not gonna lie they don't always fit in
this movie that's really what I can say
that there are a few things in this
movie quite a few things we were like
that doesn't really fit example the
human shake you know the nice one who's
in the first Rio she's in this movie
what point and purpose does she served
not much of anything except to be in Rio
- because she was in real one she's
gotta like Ali Larter in every season of
Heroes you look at her and you're like
what point do you serve tsunami and it
gets kind of config it mixed signals
from this movement from characters that
are in this movie that don't need to be
in this movie - musical sequences there
are a few musical sequences in this
movie at first there are no musical
sequences it doesn't set itself up as a
musical in the first musical sequence
hit you're like oh it's it's a musical
alright I wasn't prepared for that now
the Disney movies like The Lion King
Aladdin just right out the gate there's
a musical number to let you know you're
in a musical this movie that doesn't
happen so when the first one comes on
you're like that's should you just sing
it yourself but it's not a musical is a
few of the musical numbers they're
really cool visually speaking they look
like birds doing the Kaleidoscope thing
it looks neat that's great do I remember
a song in this mood well I do remember
one there's a take on the song I will
survive
I remember that one because I actually
know the song and it's done by again a
character from the last movie that they
she warned into this movie because Lily
had to be because he was in the last
movie who doesn't really serve a point
and purpose to this movie ironically he
was my favorite character in this movie
maybe that's the point of having him in
here
because there had to be a character that
was cool he's this prima donna who just
wants a stage he wants an audience who
wants to be evil he wants to be
traumatic he cracked me up I was like
that is a great villain I like villains
like him if only he was the villain in
the movie I say he's not because he
doesn't really do much that's the thing
the sequels got to do man if it's gonna
keep a character in the second movie
that was in the first movie make them
fit if I can't fit have the balls to cut
him from the movie I always respect
movies that are like I can't make it fit
so he's gone this movie didn't do that
so it completely loses points because it
compromises the overall experience cuz
you're left going what was the point of
these characters yeah there were some
fun jokes in the movie I was watching it
and I was like this movie in a word is
functional it's functional in the sense
that if you're a parent you have kids or
you're a babysitter and you're watching
kids you're like I want to catch Captain
America Winter Soldier again hey go
watch Rio kids and the kids will have a
good time watching Rio - that's fine but
if you're an adult you're gonna be like
I nothing's really gripping me by the
end of the movie I was like well that
was the movie I was Rio - I guess I have
the urge to play Angry Birds now maybe
that's why Rio 2 happened so it had some
fun musical numbers a couple of
memorable characters and has some really
forgettable musical numbers and really
forgettable characters kids will love it
adults will be like yeah well you know
my kids liked it as an adult speaking
for adults I'm just gonna say Rio twos
all right but you're not gonna remember
it in t-minus a couple days yep already
forgot it so Rio - have you seen it what
did you think about it more importantly
what did your kids think about it it was
meant for them whatever you or they
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]